j'ai un fuseau horaire des degrés divers
de la proportionnelle dans la plupart de
nos modes jusqu'en 1985 un an avant les
élections législatives
le président mitterrand envisage la mise
en place de la proportionnelle pourquoi
pour plus de représentativité selon la
gauche
la démographie de la france a changé
mensonge est tactique politicienne
selon les opposants ce scandale car on
ne change pas les règles du jeu à la
veille d'une compétition
et si le président de la république le
fait si le gouvernement ne fait c'est
parce qu'ils ont peur d'être battus en
effet la proportionnelle permettrait à
de plus petits partis d'entrer à
l'assemblée nationale et ainsi empêcher
l'opposition d'avoir une forte majorité
avril 1985 c'est officiel les élections
législatives se feront à la
proportionnelle à un tour scandale du
côté de l'opposition les foules
rassemblées cet après midi à un terrain
de rugby
un communiqué commun publié par le rpr
et l'udf et j'estime que le président de
la république a choisi en intérêts
personnels mais aussi au sein du parti
socialiste avec la démission immédiate
de michel rocard qu fervent opposant à
la proportionnelle et les français
qu'est ce qu'ils en pensent près d'un
français sur trois ignore comment elles
vont se dérouler la proportionnelle
connaît pas et les élections sont quand
même dans six mois
16 mars 1986 c'est le grand jour
conséquence de la stratégie de françois
mitterrand pour la première fois 35
députés du front national entre au
parlement
ça empêche la droite d'avoir une large
majorité l'humiliation électorale et
donc éviter pour le ps mais c'est bien
la droite qui remporte de peu cette
élection malgré un scrutin proportionnel
dont l'objectif à l'évidence était
d'empêcher toute majorité nouvelle
dans notre pays les français ont choisi
ils ont confié au rpr et à l'udf la
majorité absolue à l'assemblée nationale
conséquence pour la première fois sous
la vème république une cohabitation
s'instaure jacques chirac devient
premier ministre
l'une de ses premières réformes sera de
revenir au mode de scrutin majoritaire
en légiférant sans débat avec l'article
49-3 1986 restera donc la seule année où
les députés ont été élus à la
proportionnelle
[Musique]